Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Nous allons vous parler
de la psychiatrie, le naufrage
de la psychiatrie.
La psychiatrie sous toutes
ses formes et elles sont nombreuses,
car on ne réduit pas
la santé mentale à un algorithme
neuropsychologique,
cette psychiatrie donc
se porte mal.
Les difficultés rencontrées
par la psychiatrie sont
d'une part les mêmes que celles
qui affectent la médecine :
manque de moyens,
engorgement des services,
fuite vers le privé,
rémunérations insuffisantes,
perte d'attractivité,
asymétrie territoriale,
avec ce qu'on appelle
les déserts psychiatriques.
Nous observons aussi
un déclin spécifique
de la psychiatrie,
qui date de la fin des années 90
avec une stigmatisation
de la santé mentale
d'où les politiques
ne sont pas sans reproche.
De l'uniformisation impossible
de cette discipline,
qui fait appel autant à la création,
à l'imagination,
à l'écoute analytique,
à la science, à la pharmacopée,
on a bien souvent fabriqué
un monstre bureaucratique
de surveillance
psychique,
qui n'est pas adapté aux réalités
de terrain
et encore moins opérationnelles
dans un contexte social dégradé
où s'accumulent
les misères qui ont nom dépression,
schizophrénie, burn-out, suicide.
Bref, tous les exilés de l'intime,
tous les exclus de la société.
Nous allons en parler
avec mes invités.
Daniel Zagury,
vous êtes psychiatre, expert
près de la cour d'appel de Paris.
Frank Bellivier,
vous êtes psychiatre également,
délégué ministériel à la santé
mentale et à la psychiatrie.
Jean de Kervasdoué,
vous êtes ancien
directeur général des hôpitaux,
vous êtes
à l'Académie des Technologies.
Marie Giacardy,
vous êtes psychiatre
et psychanalyste.
Alors, commençons par l'actualité.
Un point d'abord
sur le manque de soignants
et ce qu'on appelle
les déserts psychiatriques.
Pourquoi et comment, Daniel Zagury ?
-Euh, alors, euh...
Ca, c'est une question essentielle.
Pourquoi cette désaffection
pour une discipline
qui est somptueuse,
pour une spécialité médicale
magnifique ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
nous voyons des jeunes psychiatres
de la quarantaine,
qui étaient taillés
pour le service public qui sont pris
dans des conflits éthiques
et qui quittent l'hôpital
pour s'installer,
pour ne pas avoir honte
de ce qu'ils font,
pour pouvoir se regarder
dans la glace ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé
à une telle situation
avec une perte d'attractivité
du choix de la psychiatrie
pour les internes,
puisqu'en termes d'attractivité,
la psychiatrie est 40e
sur 44 spécialités médicales ?
Ce qui pour quelqu'un
de ma génération est
tout à fait impensable.
-Une spécialité tiers-mondiste.
-C'est une... Effectivement,
c'est une spécialité sinistrée
pour vraiment
toute une série de raisons,
concluantes malheureusement.
-Votre point de vue, officiel,
Monsieur Bellivier ?
-Officiel... Les chiffres
nous disent d'abord... Il y a
un 1er facteur important,
la démographie médicale.
Nous sommes dans un grand creux.
Et la relève c'est-à-dire
les jeunes médecins formés
ne suffisent pas à pallier
ce manque lié aux départs.
Nous sommes d'ailleurs à la fin
de ce creux, 2023 est l'année
où la décrue s'interrompt
avant une remontée jusqu'en 2025.
Mais la relève n'est pas là.
C'est un fait.
Et les territoires les plus
en difficulté, par ce manque
de relève sont les territoires
structurellement
le plus en tension.
Il faut s'entendre aussi sur
ce qu'on appelle un désert médical.
Le 1er désert médical de France,
c'est le 93.
Il est à nos portes, c'est-à-dire
si on définit un désert médical
comme l'inadéquation
la plus importante
entre les besoins et l'offre.
Et évidemment,
les réponses à apporter
à ces types de territoires-là,
je pense au 93, ne sont pas
du tout les mêmes
que l'autre acception
du terme de désert médical,
qui sont
les grands territoires ruraux.
Et où là, évidemment,
lorsque la pénurie se fait sentir,
il y a un cercle vicieux
qui s'installe,
le travail devient pénible pour ceux
qui restent,
parce que la relève n'est pas là,
or il y a quand même des larges
territoires à couvrir.
-Jean de Kervasdoué,
peut-on dire que la psychiatrie
a les mêmes problèmes
que la médecine,
mais en plus graves ?
-Oui, parce qu'il y a une raison
générale et des raisons spécifiques.
La raison générale,
elle est simple à dire
en quelques chiffres.
On est passé de 8700 médecins
en numerus clausus
dans les années 70
à 3500
entre 95 et 2000.
Donc, comme on recrute
les jeunes médecins à 19, 20 ans,
les gens qui ont
40, 45 ans, c'est des gens
du creux de la vague
des années 90,
puisque c'est à l'âge,
40 ans, 45 ans,
où on devient chef de service,
et on s'aperçoit
qu'ils n'existent pas.
Il y a par ailleurs
un 2e problème, c'est que,
mais on en reparlera, je pense,
c'est qu'on a voulu
normaliser la psychiatrie.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
autrefois, les psychiatres
étaient les seuls médecins salariés
avant la réforme des PH
et les professeurs d'université.
-PH, c'est praticiens
hospitaliers.
-Oui.
-Et il y a eu
un concours de psychiatres
qui était un concours spécifique.
Le problème aujourd'hui, on voit ça,
c'est ce que disait Daniel Zagury,
dans le choix
des spécialités à l'internat,
à mon avis,
on ne devient pas psychiatre
parce que on n'a pas réussi
à être chirurgien.
Il y a un problème de la politique
menée depuis une trentaine d'années,
qui a fait disparaître
les mots spécifiques sur la
psychiatrie et la santé mentale,
en prétendant que c'était une
spécialité comme les autres.
C'est le problème essentiel. Un 3e
et dernier problème, c'est que
il y a d'énormes variations,
puisqu'il y a
des secteurs psychiatriques
qui n'ont pas de psychiatres
et les variations de moyens
entre secteurs psychiatriques
varient de 1 à 10, ce qui est
absolument considérable
et encore beaucoup plus que dans
les autres secteurs de la médecine.
-Marie Giacardy, vous, vous avez
l'avantage, si on peut dire,
d'être un psychiatre,
psychanalyste
de terrain.
Vous direz dans quelles
conditions vous travaillez.
Est-ce que vous constatez
que ce numerus clausus crée
des situations
de pénurie ? Et j'aimerais
avec vous
avoir une réponse
à une préoccupation
forte aujourd'hui.
En ce qui concerne les urgences,
est-ce qu'il est exact
que c'est un parcours
du combattant
pour pouvoir se soigner ?
-Oui, absolument. C'est ce
qu'on constate sur le terrain.
D'abord, pour aller...
pour donner quelques explications
peut-être au manque d'attractivité
de la spécialité, c'est
une discipline très singulière.
Qui demande des capacités
de résistance
aux paradigmes de notre société,
à savoir qu'elle repose
sur un savoir
qui se construit uniquement
dans la relation
avec le patient
et dans l'espace intersubjectif.
Donc cela se heurte
à des paradigmes sociétaux,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a affaire
à une part d'incertitude,
quotidienne, et il faut donc pouvoir
supporter cette part d'incertitude.
C'est une spécialité purement
clinique, aucun moyen de prouver
le diagnostic, qui s'établit
dans l'intersubjectivité.
Et ça n'a rien à voir
avec le discours
de l'Evidence Based Medicine
dans laquelle nous sommes baignés
durant nos études
et notre exercice. Nous ne pouvons
pas prouver ce que nous avançons.
D'autre part, nous travaillons
dans un espace-temps
qui est très différent
et qui doit nous décaler
de la course folle
que nous vivons dans la société
actuelle, puisque le temps psychique
est un temps long.
Il faut du temps
pour rencontrer le patient,
instaurer un climat de confiance,
comprendre ce qui se passe,
où va se loger sa souffrance.
Et nous ne pouvons pas assurer
ou nous devons expliquer d'emblée
au patient et à sa famille
que nous n'allons pas avoir
un résultat immédiat.
Nous n'allons pas
avoir une efficacité immédiate.
Non, ça n'ira pas mieux demain.
En ce qui concerne
le parcours du combattant,
oui, c'en est un. D'abord parce
qu'il y a une dégradation,
une détérioration de la santé
mentale, mais qui est antérieure
à la crise de la pandémie.
On y reviendra
certainement.
Et donc il y a certes
une pénurie de psychiatres,
mais il y a une explosion
des demandes de soins
qui a à voir
avec cette dégradation
de la santé mentale,
qui fait que nous avons à peu près
3 à... Enfin, les personnes,
qui sont en demande,
attendent parfois 3 à 6 mois
avant de pouvoir
rencontrer un psychiatre.
Que lorsqu'un psychiatre
s'installe en cabinet privé,
son cabinet est plein en un mois
et pour qu'il s'occupe bien
de sa patientèle,
il doit refuser
les nouvelles demandes
ou bien encore pire,
faire le tri des demandes,
selon des critères d'urgence
et notamment le risque suicidaire
qui est majeur
dans la population actuelle
et qui touche
surtout les jeunes de 11
à 25 ans.
-Dans quel cadre travaillez-vous ?
-Je travaille en clinique. Je
travaille dans deux endroits,
en clinique privée, dans une
institution privée d'hospitalisation
de Senlis
et en cabinet de consultation.
-Monsieur Bellivier,
je m'intéresse à vous
sur la question de la formation.
Les psychiatres
et les infirmiers psychiatriques
avaient l'habitude
de travailler ensemble.
Aujourd'hui, à vous écouter,
la psychiatrie n'est plus
une spécialité médicale,
mais on va former
pendant deux ans,
si mon information est bonne,
des infirmiers
en pratique avancée.
Autant dire que la santé mentale
est dans un trou, là.
En termes de personnel.
-Juste un commentaire
sur les propos de ma collègue.
Avant la crise Covid,
les suivis épidémiologiques
de la population française
ne montraient pas
une dégradation
de la santé mentale des Français.
En revanche, on a vu,
ces 10, 20 dernières années,
un nombre croissant de demandes
converger vers la psychiatrie, ce
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle.
La réticence à solliciter une aide
psychologique ou une aide médicale
psychiatrique,
eh bien, s'est atténuée.
Et la démarche d'aller voir
un psychologue ou un psychiatre
s'est démocratisée,
c'est devenu plus facile.
La crise Covid
a épidémiologiquement
sur l'ensemble de la population
française montré une dégradation
des indicateurs de dépression,
d'anxiété, de troubles du sommeil
et d'idées suicidaires.
Je réponds à votre question.
La formation des... La démarche
de formation des infirmiers
en pratique avancée
spécialisés en santé
mentale vise
à satisfaire cette idée,
face à la pénurie de psychiatres,
de faciliter
une délégation de tâches
en direction d'infirmiers
qui ont reçu
spécifiquement une formation
pour recevoir
cette délégation de tâches.
Donc ce n'est...
Je pense que ça va enrichir
le parcours de santé mentale
des patients qui ont besoin
d'une continuité...
-Oui, mais quand ?
Le problème est qu'il manque
à la fois des psychiatres et on va
former des infirmiers,
ça prendra quelques années,
comment on va faire là, maintenant ?
Parce qu'on a
un embouteillage psychique
si je puis
utiliser cette expression triviale.
-On court après cette inadéquation
entre les besoins et l'offre.
C'est pas les infirmiers
de pratique avancée
qui seront quelques milliers
dans quelques années
qui aujourd'hui
sont quelques centaines.
Donc effectivement c'est plutôt
une réponse moyen terme
qu'une réponse long terme.
-Je veux pas
vous taquiner, mais je voudrais
demander
à Monsieur Zagury,
quand vous entendez
Monsieur Bellivier dire
qu'il y a une inadéquation
entre l'offre et la demande,
ça veut dire que la psychiatrie
rentre dans un champ économique
et elle est dévoyée
de sa vocation, non ?
Je sais pas.
Je cherche pas la polémique,
mais ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il y a là quelque chose...
-Je crois que c'est très important
que les psychiatres justement
qui font,
qui sont dans une discipline
extrêmement hétérogène,
extrêmement diversifiée,
extrêmement riche,
mais c'est à la fois
leur talon d'Achille
et leur richesse. Et c'est
très important que les psychiatres,
quel que soit le courant
qu'ils représentent,
soient unitaires et aient
une défense de la profession.
Il n'y a pas
de Pic de la Mirandole psychiatre
qui sache tout,
la psychiatrie biologique,
l'épidémiologie,
la relation, la psychanalyse,
c'est pas vrai, ça n'existe pas.
Mais tous, nous sommes au service
d'une psychiatrie intégrative
qui est pour le patient
et qui utilise toutes les ressources
de la connaissance dans l'intérêt
de ce patient. Moi, j'ai
pas du tout un esprit polémique.
Si vous avez lu mon livre,
vous avez vu que ça me paraît
extrêmement important, parce que...
-Vous êtes pas polémique,
mais vous dites
qu'on massacre la psychiatrie.
-Je dis qu'on massacre la
psychiatrie,
parce que, quand vous... Alors,
je dis ça à deux niveaux.
Au niveau d'une part des chiffres.
Au niveau... Bon.
Qui est démontrable.
Et au niveau de ma carrière,
de mon parcours,
au moment où j'ai pris
ma retraite hospitalière,
en essayant de comprendre pourquoi
j'ai commencé dans l'enthousiasme
et pourquoi
j'ai fini
dans cette espèce de marasme.
Vous parliez du 93 tout à l'heure,
j'ai travaillé
dans le 93 toute ma carrière,
mais dans le 93, il y avait
des psychiatres très dynamiques
qui ont fait une psychiatrie
de secteur très active,
et à la fin
de mon parcours, j'ai pu voir
des choses inimaginables,
c'est-à-dire la pénurie,
le recours exagéré à l'isolement
et à la contention,
une bureaucratie
totalement écrasante.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail de tout ça.
-C'est-à-dire beaucoup de choses.
-Jean de Kervasdoué,
une petite précision,
je m'adresse à vous aussi,
je sais que vous êtes un économiste
de la santé. Quelle part
l'économie, par exemple,
le paiement à l'acte,
dans le cas de la psychiatrie,
quelle part l'économie a
dans le dévoiement
de la psychiatrie ?
-Je ne vais pas répondre
tout de suite à cette question,
je vais simplement lever un lièvre
qui n'est pas évident
pour les gens qui nous écoutent,
mais qui est évident entre nous,
c'est qu'il y a à l'intérieur
du monde de la santé mentale
des débats épistémologiques
et théoriques qui sont violents.
Ce que dit Daniel Zagury,
ce que vous dites aussi, Monsieur,
c'est qu'il faudrait
que tout le monde
travaille ensemble,
comme dans le domaine du cancer,
où radiothérapeutes,
chirurgiens et médecins
travaillent ensemble
et il y a à l'intérieur
du monde de la psychiatrie
des querelles d'écoles,
qui sont, qui posent des problèmes.
-Vous allez voir
qu'on va aborder précisément
cette question.
-Deux mots d'économie.
Alors, la France, et vous allez voir
que c'est paradoxal
ce que je vais dire,
la France est le pays de l'OCDE,
40 pays riches,
qui dépense le plus
pour la santé mentale
en pourcentage
de ses dépenses de santé.
Donc la France dépense 15 %
de ses dépenses de santé
en santé mentale.
La moyenne de l'OCDE, écoutez bien,
c'est 6,7.
Bien. Alors, où est la différence ?
Où est l'erreur ? Elle est
dans la prescription
des psychotropes
par les généralistes.
L'essentiel de ce que l'on compte
dans les dépenses de santé mentale,
c'est pas le fonctionnement
des secteurs psychiatriques,
c'est pas la médecine libérale,
c'est pas les consultations,
ce sont les prescriptions.
La deuxième...
La deuxième remarque économique,
c'est que tout ce qui a été dit
jusqu'à présent,
c'est qu'effectivement,
la psychiatrie manque
de moyens à organisation
inchangée.
Donc comme nous avons en stock
beaucoup d'argent,
vous avez en France aussi
en valeur absolue
et pas relative
beaucoup de psychiatres,
beaucoup plus
que la plupart des pays occidentaux,
c'est que donc
nous avons un problème
collectif d'organisation
que nous refusons de regarder.
Et que...
Toutes choses étant égales
par ailleurs,
les deux discours sont vrais.
Quand vous dites,
on manque de moyens, c'est vrai.
On en manque
parce que l'augmentation
des dépenses en psychiatrie a été
très inférieure à l'inflation
et à d'autres considérations.
Les secteurs psychiatriques ont eu
de moins en moins d'argent,
mais collectivement,
nous en dépensons beaucoup.
Il faudrait que collectivement,
et cette émission nous aide,
on regarde
le problème d'organisation.
-Alors, un peu d'histoire.
Après la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale, nous avons observé
une prise de conscience collective,
pour humaniser
la psychiatrie
et la sortir, si on peut dire,
de cette concentration asilaire.
Est-ce qu'on assiste
à un retour en arrière aujourd'hui
à travers la bureaucratisation
des pratiques,
à travers la stigmatisation
de la santé mentale ?
Monsieur Zagury ?
-Vous avez raison, partons de 1945,
partons de l'après-guerre.
Il y a eu quelque chose
de tout à fait exceptionnel,
qui était la convergence
d'une sensibilité collective :
plus jamais ça, plus jamais
l'univers concentrationnaire,
d'un certain nombre
de personnes
dans la haute
administration française
et de jeunes psychiatres
qui ont mis en place
la psychothérapie institutionnelle
et ensuite le secteur.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez eu
tout un mouvement convergent
de désaliénisme,
qui... et qu'on va retrouver
avec le secteur
et avec la psychiatrie
de ma génération,
quand j'ai commencé
dans l'enthousiasme,
c'est-à-dire que nous avions
un système de santé,
et nous avons pu vérifier
sur le terrain
sa fécondité quand,
dans certains lieux, on travaillait,
quand on était créatif. Et tout ça
effectivement, progressivement,
s'est délité, du fait
de contraintes
économiques,
du fait de cette division
dont parlait Jean de Kervasdoué
tout à l'heure
des psychiatres. Alors,
moi, je pense que les psychiatres
ont une immense responsabilité
dans la situation actuelle,
parce qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
à maintenir
l'unité de leur discipline,
une unité... vous savez,
très difficile.
Quand j'étais jeune, quand Henri Ey,
Daumézon...
-Qui sont des noms
de grands psychiatres.
-Voilà. On les écoutait.
On n'était pas nécessairement
d'accord avec eux,
mais leur parole portait,
car on savait
que, sur le terrain,
ils avaient montré
à quel point ils défendaient
notre discipline.
C'est quelque chose qui s'est perdu.
-Est-ce que Marie Giacardy
vous constatez dans votre exercice
cet éparpillement, c'est-à-dire
la non-convergence entre une
approche thérapeutique classique
et la psychanalyse,
la neuropsychiatrie ?
Ca se défait,
cette chose-là ?
-Alors,
je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous,
ça a été très vrai
jusqu'à maintenant,
c'est-à-dire
que nous avons tous fonctionné
un peu prisonniers ou dans le dogme
de nos champs de savoirs.
La psychanalyse, les sciences
cognitivo-comportementales,
les neurosciences et autres,
en se livrant des guéguerres
et en essayant de faire passer
notre champ de savoirs
comme le dogme
de ceux qui allaient
le mieux soigner la personne.
Maintenant, bien obligés
de fonctionner différemment
et tant mieux, c'est-à-dire
qu'il va falloir penser
la santé mentale
avec le primat du lien, à savoir
que ça va être au-delà du colloque
singulier médecin-malade.
L'idée, c'est d'identifier
et de rassembler les relations
ressources qui existent
autour de la personne
et de faire travailler ensemble
plusieurs professionnels
de la santé mentale, car
nous ne sommes pas, heureusement,
les psychiatres, les seuls acteurs
de la santé mentale.
Pour expliquer
clairement et brièvement,
prenons la métaphore
du filet de Norbert Elias.
Comment est formé un filet ?
Chacun des fils est
une unité en soi,
et ce qui va faire
la structure du filet,
c'est la façon dont sont tissés
les fils entre eux.
Il est devenu maintenant impératif
de penser les choses comme ça,
sur un maillage
collectif
d'un ensemble d'intervenants
en santé mentale.
Et je loue tout à fait, moi,
la création de la profession
d'infirmier de pratique avancée.
Je reçois dans mon cabinet en stage
le mois prochain une infirmière
de pratique avancée,
ils ont besoin de faire
des stages, car ils pourront
enrichir notre discipline,
certes désobstruer les urgences,
mais ils pourront intervenir
à beaucoup de niveaux,
mais dans ce tissage
où le psychiatre va
peut-être devenir alors
un coordinateur de soins, puisque
leur pratique en santé mentale
va reposer sur un contrat
avec le psychiatre.
Le psychiatre coordonnera les soins,
mais ça se passera... Il faut...
On n'en est plus à la division.
C'est trop grave.
Il faut repenser le soin.
Sinon on n'arrivera pas à soigner
correctement les personnes.
-On va demander votre avis,
Monsieur Bellivier,
sur ce tissage,
ce tressage. Est-ce qu'on est
conscient au niveau des pouvoirs
publics qu'il faut
intégrer les innovations,
les expérimentations ? Parce que
c'est pas...
J'allais dire, c'est pas
une discipline ordinaire,
elle nécessite l'imagination,
la science, l'analyse, etc.
Et est-ce que
vous facilitez cette chose-là ?
-Deux réponses à votre question.
La première, assez personnelle,
je me reconnais
dans ce qui vient d'être dit,
je pense que ces guerres théoriques
sont derrière nous.
J'appartiens à une génération
qui a fait l'intégration
de ces différents savoirs,
qui font toute la richesse
de la formation des psychiatres.
Et c'est vrai
pour la génération qui arrive.
Ils ont réussi à intégrer
ces différents courants
de pensée,
de technique psychothérapique
et situer l'acte médical un peu
au carrefour de ces différents
savoirs. Donc je pense
que c'est aujourd'hui quelque chose
qui peut être revendiqué
comme une richesse.
Au niveau des pouvoirs publics,
on est athéoriques.
On n'est pas une société savante.
Le ministère de la Santé
n'est pas une société savante.
Et donc le raisonnement
du ministère de la Santé,
c'est comme dans les autres
disciplines la promotion
des recommandations
de bonne pratique
et des données probantes.
Ca, d'une certaine manière,
ça doit pouvoir
s'appliquer au champ
des soins psychiatriques
comme au champ des soins
psychologiques d'ailleurs
pour les psychothérapies. Donc,
voilà, s'agissant des innovations,
la feuille de route santé mentale
et psychiatrie que je pilote
au ministère fait une large place
au soutien à l'innovation
et à la recherche.
Quand on parle de recherche,
on ne parle pas
que de recherche fondamentale,
neurobiologique,
mais tous les champs
de recherche sont embarqués
par ce soutien à l'innovation.
Je voudrais revenir
sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur Zagury,
de ce moment très fécond
où se cristallise
une pensée qui aboutit
à l'organisation en secteur,
le mot que vous avez employé,
c'est qui se déliterait.
En fait, je pense
qu'il faut d'abord rappeler
que la doctrine promue,
les piliers de la loi de secteur,
n'ont pas pris
une ride. Vous retrouvez
les grands principes
promus par la loi de secteur
dans la feuille de route
santé mentale et psychiatrie,
promotion à l'ambulatoire,
les malades dans la cité, etc.
Mais ce qu'il faut entendre,
c'est que le terme secteur
recouvre trois choses.
C'est d'abord
un territoire
et ce territoire a beaucoup bougé
depuis les années 60, même si la loi
de secteur a été confirmée en 90.
Les patients ne sont plus
captifs d'un territoire.
Au sein d'un territoire,
il y a... l'acteur principal
n'est plus que le secteur.
Il y a des territoires
où il y a une offre non sectorisée,
privée, publique,
qui fait
que les patients doivent aussi
s'y retrouver là-dedans.
Deuxièmement,
le terme secteur, c'est
un projet. C'est un projet
dont le chef de service
de secteur avait la maîtrise
et il avait à concevoir
son projet de soins pour les malades
dont il avait la responsabilité,
et ce, sans référence obligatoire
aux recommandations de bonne
pratique ou aux données probantes.
En tout cas, ces recommandations
de bonne pratique
n'ont jamais été opposables.
Troisièmement, le secteur,
c'est une organisation.
En fonction des politiques portées
par les ARS et les établissements,
on a vu naître...
-Les ARS,
les agences régionales de santé.
-On a vu naître des différences
d'un établissement à un autre
et d'une région à une autre.
De tout cela,
il résulte aujourd'hui une somme
de particularismes
qui sont peu lisibles.
Je pense que les réformes
que nous portons visent,
au ministère de la Santé,
à remettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça.
-Oui, alors, écoutez,
tout ça serait parfait
si on arrivait
dans le meilleur des mondes.
Mais c'est pas forcément le cas
quand on regarde la psychiatrie.
C'est pas que je veux rentrer
dans des contradictions polémiques,
mais sur un plan politique,
Jean de Kervasdoué,
sous le gouvernement
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
alors président de la République,
et de Madame Bachelot à l'époque,
responsable de la santé,
une certaine confusion s'est opérée
entre santé mentale,
délinquance, criminalité.
Est-ce que c'est ce qui a entraîné
une judiciarisation
de la psychiatrie et ce qui l'a
éloignée de ses rails
thérapeutiques,
et qui peut expliquer
le désenchantement
de Monsieur Zagury aujourd'hui ?
-Daniel Zagury en parlerait
beaucoup mieux que moi de ça,
mais la loi du 5 juillet 2011
est un drame.
Elle est un drame,
parce qu'elle fait l'hypothèse
que les malades mentaux sont...
Certains malades mentaux
sont des tueurs en puissance.
Et ça, ça va
contre les statistiques.
Les malades mentaux
ne tuent pas plus les autres,
sauf à l'intérieur
de leur famille.
Mais la criminalité,
en dehors des familles...
Et donc, ça a conduit
à des procédures folles
qui prennent du temps
administratif,
du temps infirmier
et qui font d'ailleurs que
ces mesures ne sont pas respectées
parce qu'elles ne sont pas
respectables au sens des moyens
en personnel qu'il faudrait
pour les respecter.
Autant du côté des tribunaux
que du côté
des services de psychiatrie.
Donc,
tout cela me paraît
absolument dramatique.
Je ne suis pas certain
que les gens qui nous écoutent
sont bien conscients
des différentes armes thérapeutiques
à la disposition d'un secteur.
Je voulais juste en dire un mot
pour expliquer l'hétérogénéité.
Parce qu'un secteur psychiatrique,
ce n'est pas seulement des lits.
C'est des lits de jour,
des lits de nuit,
des consultations dans les centres
médicaux pédagogiques, etc.
Il y a toute une série de gammes
sur laquelle un secteur peut jouer
et visiblement,
il y en a
qui jouent mieux que d'autres.
La politique doit faire en sorte
que tout le monde
joue à peu près bien.
On en est relativement loin
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âme,
pas de flamme.
Vous n'avez jamais entendu...
C'est une dernière
remarque générale.
Une chose qui me frappe
en me repenchant
sur un peu plus de 50 ans
de politique de santé
dans ce pays,
c'est que les partis politiques
ne parlent jamais
d'organisation des soins.
Ils parlent uniquement
de l'accès des gens
à la médecine,
notamment le ticket modérateur,
le financement, etc.
Mais il n'y a aucun engagement
d'un parti politique
sur la santé mentale.
Il n'y a pas d'engagement
sur le drame que vit aujourd'hui
la médecine libérale.
On va voir ça
avec les problèmes de convention.
Et le drame de ce qu'il se passe
à l'hôpital,
pas uniquement psychiatrique,
mais les autres.
Je crois que Daniel
et vous, monsieur,
vous êtes mieux placés pour parler
de la loi 2011.
-Justement, Daniel Zagury,
cette loi de 2011,
qui a fait un...
...qui a tressé, peut-être,
pas un lien, mais en tout cas,
une direction entre délinquance
et psychiatrie,
a-t-elle encore
des conséquences, aujourd'hui ?
-Evidemment.
Vous avez prononcé le nom
d'un président de la République
qui a effectivement
stigmatisé les malades mentaux.
Que peut signifier une politique
d'Etat de déstigmatisation
quand le président de la République
lui-même stigmatise
les malades mentaux
en associant
criminalité et délinquance
et en instrumentalisant,
tout au long de son quinquennat,
des faits divers ?
Au point, d'ailleurs,
qu'il y quelque chose d'assez
étonnant dont je me suis aperçu
quand j'ai écrit mon livre,
c'est que la psychiatrie,
en France, dans les médias,
c'est les services
police-justice.
Mais le service santé,
de temps en temps,
ils font un très bon...
...un très bon reportage,
mais ça ne va pas plus loin
et en définitive,
ce n'est pas ça qui est central.
Donc, en effet,
durant le quinquennat
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
il y a eu d'une part la loi HPST,
c'est le directeur
qui commande et...
-Le directeur
étant un administratif.
-Voilà. Et c'est comme ça.
Cela nous a fait perdre
une quinzaine d'années.
C'est ce que disait un ancien
ministre de la Santé récemment
dans Le Monde.
Il y a donc eu la loi HPST,
il y a eu la loi de 2011
qui est une loi bureaucratique,
une loi de stigmatisation
qui n'a pas du tout
été discutée avec les psychiatres.
La loi de...
L'ancienne loi de 1838
a été discutée avec les aliénistes
pendant un an et demi.
Donc là, elle a été imposée
contre les psychiatres.
Donc...
Et vous avez, donc,
cette loi de 2011,
cette loi HPST.
Effectivement,
ça a donc été un accélérateur,
un accélérateur...
-Du démembrement ?
Oui, mais Daniel Zagury,
vous êtes expert
auprès de la cour d'appel
et très connu, d'ailleurs,
pour votre sagacité
dans ce domaine.
Mais quelquefois,
vous avez des personnes
atteintes de troubles mentaux
qui se livrent à...
...à des actes délinquants.
Ca peut arriver.
Et là,
on vous soumet ces cas-là,
la société est faite
de ces faits divers
qui existent, etc.
Comment peut-on faire
pour rassurer les opinions publiques
qui sont inquiètes,
vous le savez bien,
dès qu'il y a un crime ?
On l'a vu récemment
avec un acteur célèbre.
Que faut-il faire,
à ce niveau-là ?
-Ce qu'il faut faire, d'abord,
c'est un travail d'objectivation.
Savez-vous quel est le pourcentage
de schizophrènes qui tuent ?
-Mais il en suffit d'un
et que ce soit médiatisé.
Vous savez bien, l'opinion publique.
-Savez-vous
le pourcentage de schizophrènes
qui ne tuent pas ?
C'est 99,70 pour cent.
Donc, on ne peut pas stigmatiser
une catégorie de patients
du fait d'un rapport
avec la criminalité.
-Heureusement.
-La 2e réponse qui me paraît
la réponse la plus importante,
c'est que meilleur sera
le dispositif de santé publique,
moins il y aura
ce type de passage à l'acte criminel
lié à une affection psychiatrique.
Et si vous voulez,
l'une des raisons
qui font
que la psychiatrie n'est pas
une spécialité comme les autres,
c'est justement
ce lien dans l'opinion publique
entre violence et psychiatrie,
entre crime et psychiatrie.
Un lien dont il faut dire,
objectivement,
dans quelle mesure il existe
et dans quelle mesure
il n'existe pas.
Et un lien qu'il faut contrecarrer
par un dispositif.
La réponse la plus rationnelle,
c'est : "ayons le meilleur
dispositif de soin"
et ce type de problème
sera diminué.
-Frank Bellivier,
j'aimerais avoir votre avis
sur cette fameuse loi
de 2011 et en même temps,
en même temps,
les prisons sont pleines
de malades mentaux.
-Et la rue.
-Et la rue aussi.
Quelle est la politique
de santé mentale
au regard de ce qu'il se passe
dans nos prisons
et de ce qu'il se passe,
comme vient de le dire
Jean de Kervasdoué, dans la rue,
où il y a beaucoup de malades ?
-D'abord, sur la stigmatisation
des malades mentaux,
ou la désignation des malades
mentaux comme boucs émissaires
d'un certain nombre
de fantasmes sociétaux,
c'est une vieille histoire.
Quand un président de la République
met son grain de sel
dans cette affaire,
les représentations
sont encore renforcées
là où au contraire,
on essaye de déconstruire
ces représentations
du malade mental dangereux.
Les chiffres sont éloquents.
Une minorité...
-Donc, c'est clair,
vous condamnez cela.
-Les malades mentaux
sont bien plus victimes qu'auteurs.
Si on reprend
les données
factuelles.
J'insiste
sur les chiffres qu'a donnés
Daniel Zagury.
C'est moins de 1 pour cent
de patients schizophrènes
qui commettent, au cours
de leur vie, un acte médico-légal.
Si on prend le problème
dans l'autre sens,
quel est le pourcentage
d'actes médico-légaux
pénalement répréhensibles
commis par des personnes
ultérieurement reconnues comme
porteuses d'un trouble psychique ?
C'est moins de 1 pour cent.
Donc, quel que soit
l'angle par lequel
on prend le problème,
les faits contredisent
ces représentations.
Il faut donc lutter activement
pour déstigmatiser
ces représentations.
C'est d'ailleurs un des axes...
-Que fait-on
concernant les prisons ?
-Sur l'inflation, on a des données.
Plusieurs enquêtes ont montré
que le nombre
de personnes incarcérées
porteuses d'un trouble psychique
augmente considérablement.
Là aussi,
c'est un phénomène complexe
et plusieurs facteurs
y ont contribué.
La pénalisation des malades mentaux
est un des aspects,
parce qu'il y a
quand même eu une évolution
dans l'attitude des juges
et dans leur manière d'appliquer
les peines ou de prendre en compte
certains degrés d'irresponsabilité.
Je pense qu'on a eu
également un effet
des constats
psychiatriques immédiats
qui ont globalement disparu,
on peut le dire,
je me tourne vers Daniel Zagury,
qui ont opéré un premier filtre
et ont soustrait un certain nombre
de personnes objectivement malades
de l'instruction.
Pour certaines de ces personnes
dont l'instruction se poursuivait,
ça se terminait en prison.
Et on se retrouve avec des...
...un nombre croissant
de malades mentaux
en prison.
Ce qui pose deux questions.
La première, c'est l'organisation
des soins en prison
dans un contexte de pénurie.
Parce qu'on a aussi,
là encore,
un point d'inadéquation
entre les besoins
des personnes en prison
et l'offre
qu'on peut mettre en face.
Et deuxièmement, il y a
tout l'enjeu des sortants de prison.
-Vous êtes en train de dire
qu'il faut créer
des hôpitaux psychiatriques
qui soient en lien
avec les prisons ?
-Ce que je suis en train de dire,
c'est que oui,
des moyens supplémentaires
sont nécessaires
pour les soignants
qui interviennent en prison.
Ensuite,
il faut décider des priorités.
Une des priorités
qu'on essaye de soutenir,
c'est des dispositifs renforcés
de prise en charge
des sortants de prison
pour prévenir la désocialisation
et pour prévenir
la réincarcération. En effet,
les taux de réincarcération
sont importants,
mais ils le sont surtout
chez les personnes
porteuses
d'une pathologie psychique :
c'est plus de 60 pour 100
de réincarcération.
-Si vous me permettez
de lui poser une question.
Est-ce que, quand même,
on ne peut pas dire
que beaucoup de gens
qui sont en prison
ne devraient pas être en prison ?
-Une fois que la condamnation
est prononcée,
je pense qu'il faut
revoir les moyens
d'instruire ces dossiers
en amont de la condamnation
pour faire valoir...
-Mais si c'est en aval
de la condamnation
qu'on constate le trouble mental,
ça pose un problème.
-Bien sûr.
-Marie Giacardy,
vous, dans votre exercice,
est-ce que vous avez constaté
qu'il y a plus de violences
chez les adolescents, aujourd'hui ?
Les adolescents qui sont traités
pour des troubles mentaux.
-Oui.
-Et comment vous procédez
dans ce cas-là ?
-Je vais juste faire un pas de côté,
car je vais centrer mon propos
sur votre question
sur la violence auto-infligée.
Parce que c'est le coeur
de notre quotidien
dans la clinique actuelle,
avec un nombre croissant...
-C'est-à-dire que les malades...
-De tentatives de suicide.
Les derniers chiffres que j'ai lus,
c'est 25 morts
par jour en France par suicide
et aux alentours de 700 passages
à l'acte suicidaire graves.
-Surtout
chez les jeunes ?
-Oui, c'est-à-dire les 11-25 ans,
particulièrement les 11-17 ans.
Et maintenant,
nous voyons des enfants de 10 ans
avoir des conduites suicidaires
en exprimant
une réelle intention de mourir.
C'est ça qui a changé.
Ca n'est plus scénarisé
comme un appel à l'aide extérieur.
De plus en plus,
les personnes
expriment une réelle souffrance,
dévastatrice,
avec une réelle intention de mort
et des scénarios
très précis pour ne pas se rater.
Nous gérons au quotidien des crises
suicidaires chez les jeunes
avec une inflation
des passages aux urgences
d'environ 30 pour cent
pour des passages
à l'acte suicidaires
ou des idées suicidaires
très scénarisées.
C'est cela, notre quotidien,
plus que les violences
hétéro-agressives.
Il y a une flambée
de ces violences
qu'elles soient
un passage à l'acte suicidaire
ou un geste auto-agressif
de scarification.
-Pour le préciser
à l'égard des téléspectateurs,
à votre avis,
ces passages à l'acte sont-ils liés
aux réseaux sociaux ?
Ont-ils été
particulièrement forts
au moment du COVID ?
D'où vient ce...
Il faut le dire,
même si le mot n'est pas très joli,
il y a un certain ensauvagement
qui pénalise
nos jeunes générations.
Durant le COVID,
pendant le premier confinement,
il y a eu une nette baisse
des passages aux urgences
concernant les passages
à l'acte suicidaires.
-Les gens étaient confinés.
-Pendant le confinement,
il y a eu un effet
de sidération
de cette crise pandémique
qui nous rappelait que
nous étions vulnérables et mortels.
Il y a un effet de sidération,
une recherche de solidarité
et de partage collectif.
Mais après, avec la durée
de la crise sanitaire,
bien sûr,
les passages à l'acte ont flambé.
Vous me posez la question
des réseaux sociaux,
ils sont à double tranchant.
La personne qui souffre
psychiquement est très isolée
dans sa souffrance.
Donc, ça peut être positif
quand ça la relie
à une interactivité,
à un partage des souffrances,
à l'impression
de se sentir moins seul.
Ca, c'est le bon aspect
des réseaux sociaux.
L'aspect qui nous préoccupe,
c'est autour
des procédés de harcèlement
qui vont maintenant
au-delà du temps scolaire
et qui se continuent
sur les réseaux sociaux
avec des process d'intimidation
très graves, d'une part,
et d'autre part, la contagion
de symptômes anxio-dépressifs
et les comportements,
chez les adolescents,
par mimétisme, qui créent donc
un collectif de souffrance
qui peut être inductible,
qui peut induire
le trouble anxio-dépressif.
Et quelque chose
de beaucoup plus dangereux encore,
sur le réseau TikTok
en particulier,
pour ne pas le citer,
mais bien obligé,
parce que ça nous est rapporté
par beaucoup de jeunes.
Il y a des scénarisations
de passage à l'acte
où l'on peut vous expliquer
comment ne pas se rater.
"Tu as des idées suicidaires ?
"Je vais t'expliquer
comment ne pas te rater."
C'est très grave et il n'y a pas
assez de contrôle public là-dessus,
car nous le voyons au quotidien.
-Jean de Kervasdoué,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de cette aggravation
de la situation
des Français,
notamment des jeunes générations
et est-ce habituel
qu'une crise,
en l'occurrence le COVID,
une crise majeure,
provoque autant d'aggravation ?
-Alors...
Ce que vous avez dit, madame,
c'est un phénomène...
Dans le premier épisode,
ça a été l'inverse,
comme en période de guerre
où l'on a beaucoup
moins d'expression
de la maladie mentale...
-Absolument.
-...et de tentatives de suicide.
La France a toujours été un pays
où l'on se suicide beaucoup
avec de très fortes
variations régionales.
J'avais regardé cela
dans une région chère à mon coeur
qui est la Bretagne.
On n'explique pas qu'entre la partie
bretonnante de la Bretagne
qui est au Far West
et la partie gallo, comme on dit,
il y ait des variations
du taux de suicide de 1 à 4.
En gros, en Ille-et-Vilaine,
on se suicide comme en France,
mais dans le Finistère,
on se suicide 3 à 4 fois plus,
pour des raisons
qu'on n'explique pas
et qui sont anciennes.
Il y a des variations culturelles.
Moi, je n'ai pas de chiffres
sur les jeunes générations
et sur cette violence,
mais il est clair
qu'en France, ça ne va pas bien,
qu'on a beaucoup de signes
et notamment
cette activité.
Mais je voudrais juste,
avant que cette émission
ne se termine,
évoquer un problème
qu'on n'a pas encore touché
qui est celui
de l'autre côté d'une vie,
c'est-à-dire celui
des problèmes psychiatriques
des personnes âgées.
Parce que...
Une de mes grandes critiques
aux nombreux ministres de la Santé,
et notamment ceux
d'il y a 20 ou 30 ans,
parce qu'on paye
leur incompétence aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas vu
les conséquences
du vieillissement
de la génération du baby-boom.
Or, il y a trois âges importants
en politique sociale :
il y a l'âge de la retraite
dont je ne parlerai pas,
il y a 70 ans
qui est l'âge moyen à l'hôpital
et il y a 83-85 ans qui est
l'âge d'entrée en dépendance.
Donc, quand vous regardez...
Or, il y a une partie santé mentale
de la dépendance qui est très...
la prévalence.
Donc, on va rentrer
dans une période 2030,
le début de la génération
du baby-boom,
avec une demande
de soins psychiatriques
qui va être très forte
pour les personnes âgées.
-Il nous reste peu de temps.
Je vais vous donner la parole,
M. Frank Bellivier.
Je voudrais que vous concluiez
sur ce point-là.
Le tableau
de la psychiatrie en France
n'est pas en bon état.
Il est naufragé,
il est massacré
selon M. Zagury.
Vous venez d'entendre
ce que vient de dire
Marie Giacardy
au niveau du terrain, etc.
Est-ce qu'il faut une loi-cadre,
aujourd'hui,
pour réenchanter la psychiatrie
et redonner espoir
sur une santé mentale
qui ne serait plus considérée,
comme un déchet humain,
en quelque sorte ?
Parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de réforme,
de réforme, de réforme, mais là,
n'y a-t-il pas une urgence ?
-Je vais commencer
par un propos un peu général.
Puisque vous m'avez taquiné
tout à l'heure,
si vous le permettez,
je vais vous taquiner à mon tour.
-Allez-y.
-Il se trouve que je suis marin.
Et le naufrage,
c'est quand
on ne peut plus rien faire,
sur un bateau.
Et je pense que la situation
de la psychiatrie,
aujourd'hui,
c'est tout le contraire.
On a des vents défavorables,
un avis de tempête
et il faut que tout le monde
soit sur le pont.
Je trouve qu'on a aujourd'hui,
quand je dis
"c'est tout le contraire",
qu'on a une situation assez inédite,
me semble-t-il,
pour que la psychiatrie
puisse répondre
à tous ces défis :
un engagement politique et financier
qui est tout à fait inédit.
On n'a jamais eu
un président de la République
qui a commandé des assises,
qui les a conclues.
-Mais on dit toujours ça.
A chaque fois
qu'il y a un nouveau président,
on dit que...
-Le fait est que nous avons
aujourd'hui un programme de réforme
qui se poursuit
dans le temps depuis 2018.
Je ne dis pas qu'il a produit
des effets permettant de répondre
à cette situation, mais je voulais
aussi donner les signes de vitalité.
Et je pense que
cet engagement politique
est un premier signe de vitalité.
Je note,
après deux tours de France,
un engagement nouveau
des administrations décentralisées
que sont
les Agences Régionales de Santé.
Et pour animer
les référents en santé mentale,
le sujet est pris également
par les administrations régionales.
La jeune génération,
dont la voix commence à porter
et qui a des idées
et veut faire valoir
cette psychiatrie
qu'elle veut porter pour demain.
On a l'habitude de dire
que la relève ne sera pas là,
mais plein d'indicateurs laissent
penser que la relève est là.
-Oui, mais une loi-cadre ?
Oui ou non ?
-Il y a eu beaucoup de choses,
ces dernières années,
depuis le lancement
de cette feuille de route,
avec des...
-Manifestement,
c'est insuffisant.
-...avec des réformes en profondeur
qui se déploient,
des réformes du mode de financement,
des organisations territoriales,
des autorisations,
une incitation à l'innovation,
les équipes mobiles,
les stratégies intersectorielles...
Ca part un peu
dans beaucoup de directions.
Je ne sais pas si
c'est une loi-cadre qu'il faut,
mais il faut un discours
qui réunifie l'ensemble
de cette vision,
qui l'explicite,
qui donne le sens de cette démarche
et qui réactualise
ces grands principes
qui ont été donnés
par la loi de secteur,
mais remis au goût du jour
avec les défis d'aujourd'hui,
car les attentes ont changé,
la société a évolué.
-Il nous reste
très peu de temps.
-Sur la question des violences
que vous avez posée tout à l'heure.
-Très brièvement.
-Oui. Juste indiquer
qu'un sujet
doit être pris en considération
de manière très importante,
c'est celui
de la montée des addictions,
surtout chez les jeunes, qui elles,
sont pourvoyeuses de violence.
-Merci, M. Bellivier.
M. Zagury,
êtes-vous convaincu ?
On a très peu de temps.
Et que proposeriez-vous ?
Mais vraiment...
Je suis désolé
de vous poser
cette question en une minute.
-Ce que vient de dire
Franck Bellivier est important.
Nous sommes sortis d'un déni d'Etat.
J'ai participé à une émission
de télévision avec Agnès Buzyn,
j'ai vu combien elle était...
Elle n'est pas restée longtemps
ministre de la Santé, mais
elle a fait sortir l'Etat du déni.
Ca me paraît extrêmement important.
Ce que je proposerais,
c'est la suppression de la loi HPST,
qui est une loi bureaucratique,
la suppression de la loi de 2011
avec une loi en concertation
avec les psychiatres,
une loi-cadre sur la psychiatrie,
ça me paraît extrêmement important,
pour restaurer le lien entre
le pays et sa psychiatrie publique.
C'est déjà trois réformes.
Et surtout, surtout,
une modification du rapport
entre la gestion et le soin
parce que le drame,
dans ce pays,
c'est qu'on a confié
les rênes du pouvoir
à la gestion, à l'administration,
au détriment des intelligences
collectives et de la créativité.
-Merci, M. Zagury.
Vous pourriez
souffler ces trois réformes
au ministre de la Santé,
M. Braun, ou peut-être plus haut,
à M. Macron,
c'est à vous de le savoir.
Merci, madame, merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission.
Mais d'abord, une bibliographie.
Je voudrais rappeler,
Daniel Zagury, que vous avez publié
"Comment on massacre
la psychiatrie française"
aux éditions
de l'Observatoire.
Vous y montrez
cette dégradation qui s'est faite
au cours du temps, notamment
en impliquant les politiques.
Jean de Kervasdoué,
vous venez de publier
"La santé à vif".
Cela fait plusieurs années
que vous cherchez à sauver
le système de santé.
Vous n'êtes pas lassé
de faire ce travail-là ?
-Non, parce que
j'ai cherché un moyen
de l'expliquer
de manière simple
et de ne pas écrire uniquement
pour mes collègues sociologues,
politologues, universitaires,
mais d'expliquer au grand public
que tout cela était compréhensible.
-Très bien.
Une critique de la psychiatrie
et de la situation,
Mathieu Bellahsen
et Rachel Knaebel,
"La révolte de la psychiatrie",
aux éditions de La Découverte.
C'est une critique
de notre modèle psychiatrique.
Et je voudrais signaler,
de Frank Bellivier
et Emmanuel Haffen...
Vous avez publié
"Actualités
sur les maladies dépressives"
chez Lavoisier Médecine.
Est-ce que finalement,
vous n'avez pas le sentiment
que le mot "dépression"
recouvre, pour la population,
l'ensemble des problèmes
de santé mentale ?
-Je pense quand même que
l'on peut trouver des délimitations,
même si elles ont été confessées
par ma collègue,
entre de grands registres
de symptômes.
Les troubles de l'humeur
sont une vaste famille de troubles
et on ne peut pas résumer
la souffrance psychique
à la dépression,
même si le terme est polysémique.
Employé dans le langage courant,
il recouvre souvent
des réalités différentes.
-Merci, madame,
messieurs.
Avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP d'avoir permis
la réalisation de cette émission.
Je vous laisse
avec cette citation :
"Les maladies de l'homme
ne sont pas seulement
"des limitations
de son pouvoir physique,
"ce sont des drames
de son histoire."
De qui est-ce, d'après vous ?
Ah, vous séchez.
Pourtant,
c'est un grand ancêtre.
Georges Canguilhem.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA